große nachfrage knappes gut die
opposition drängt die bundesregierung
zügig für merkur ohne impfstoff zu
sorgen
ende der blockade us-präsident trump
macht den weg frei für ein neues
bewohner hilfspaket von 900 milliarden
dollar start der vierschanzentournee
große hoffnung bei den deutschen
top-springern in oberstdorf wie polen
dagegen werden ausgeschlossen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten mit sport
natürlich den norbert lehmann wenig
später präsentiert transporter von
30.000 so viele menschen sind bis heute
in deutschland am und mit dem corona
virus gestorben
in einem jahr und noch immer stecken
sich viel zu viele an
aus einigen bundesländern kommt daher
die empfehlung die kontakt
beschränkungen über den zehnten januar
hinaus beizubehalten
zwar lässt die impfkampagne auf ein ende
der maßnahmen hoffen doch braucht es
dafür wohl einen langen atem bis neuer
sollen 1,3 millionen impfdosen von
beyond eckpfeiler hierzulande
ausgeliefert sein
für nächstes jahr sind 85 millionen
dosen bestellt
dazu kommen noch die impfseren anderer
hersteller
aber wann b zugelassen werden ist unklar
bei moderner könnte es anfang januar
soweit sein
momentan ist impfstoff jedenfalls knapp
thomas garcia stuttgart kulturzentrum
großveranstaltung aber statt konzerten
gibt es hier corona schutz
das problem weniger als 1000 spritzen
wird man täglich setzen vielmehr könnten
es sein
zusätzlich ist die infrastruktur und die
personelle ausstattung auf mindestens
zweieinhalb tausend impfungen am tag
ausgelegt das können wir im moment
leider noch nicht leisten weil die im
stoff kontingente begrenzt sind das
ersehnte sehr um etwa zu knapp der kampf
gegen korona mit der spritze zu langsam
ist das ein problem in ganz deutschland
die bundesregierung erwartet dass bis
ende märz 11 bis 13 millionen impfdosen
von bayern tag zur verfügung stehen
jeder mensch braucht zwei heißt der
stoff reicht für maximal 6,5 millionen
hinzu kommen wohl weitere präparate aber
erstmal nicht so viele reicht alles
nicht sagt die opposition
die bundesregierung muss jetzt rasch mit
der pharmazeutischen industrie
zusammenkommen um zu prüfen welche
möglichkeiten es gibt damit schneller
geimpft werden kann
das ist eine frage die im zweifel über
leben und tod entscheidet
und die auch geeignet ist
wirtschaftlichen schaden in unserem land
zu reduzieren
konkrete forderung der hersteller so
lizenzen vergeben an firmen die dann
ebenfalls produzieren das müsse man
erzwingen fordert gar die linkspartei
widerspruch eine produktion für einen
impfstoff ist hoch anspruchsvoll und
hochkomplex die kann man nicht mal eben
per lizenz bei einem anderen unternehmen
machen außerdem sorge der hersteller für
mehr impfstoff in einem neuen werk in
marburg ab februar aber gibt es auch
genug im personal fachkräfte sind rar
freiwillige arbeiten oft nicht
durchgehend kein problem bislang in
stuttgart im start gelungen mit vielen
helfern aber wie gesagt nicht so vielen
impfdosen
das robert-koch-institut hat heute
erstmals zahlen zu den corona impfungen
in deutschland herausgegeben
zum impfstart am wochenende haben
demnach bei uns knapp 18.500 menschen
ihre erste dosis bekommen
es fehlen hier aber daten aus hessen bei
den neuinfektionen registrierte das lka
10 1976 binnen 24 stunden
die zahl der toten stieg um 348
allerdings haben rund um weihnachten
nicht alle gesundheitsämter daten
übermittelt in die usa
dort hat präsident trump nun doch das
corona hilfspaket freigegeben
auf dass sich demokraten und
republikaner schon vor tagen geeinigt
hatten es sieht hilfen in höhe von 900
milliarden dollar vor
und zwar für millionen menschen die
wegen der virus krise ihren job verloren
haben
für mieter die nun weiterhin vor
zwangsräumung räumungen geschützt sind
und für unternehmen die in not geraten
waren
britta jäger aus washington die korona
pandemie hat christina kelly arbeitslos
gemacht seit august kann sie die miete
für das haus nicht mehr bezahlen
vor dem rausschmiss war die familie
bislang gesetzlich geschützt die hilfen
aber drohten nun auszulaufen
es gibt keine optionen für uns die
notunterkünfte sind für neue leute wegen
der korona krise beschlossen
ich habe noch nicht einmal ein auto in
dem wir schlafen können
ein neues us hilfspaket christinas
letzte hoffnung über monate hatte
washington darüber zäh verhandelt es
sollte die finanzielle not millionen
amerikaner linda doch dann lag der
entwurf tage lang auf donald trumps
schreibtisch statt einer unterschrift
gab es bilder vom golf spielenden
präsidenten in florida spontan wollte
der für bedürftige eine erhöhung der
einmalzahlung durchboxen von 600 auf
2000 dollar
am sonntag abend vermeldet vom auf
twitter dann gute nachrichten und gibt
seine blockadehaltung auf ich
applaudiere dem präsidenten zu seiner
entscheidung twitter der mehrheitsführer
im senat mitch mcconnell
seine republikaner hatten sich gegen
trumps idee gewährt die demokraten
dagegen hatten schon immer eine erhöhung
gefordert deren chefin im
repräsentantenhaus nancy pelosi will nun
erneut darüber abstimmen lassen
der streit um die milliarden hilfen ist
in washington noch nicht beendet
trotzdem viele amerikaner können nun
erst einmal aufatmen dringend benötigtes
geld ist für sie auf dem weg der
handelspakt für die zeit nach dem break
cit steht das war die topmeldung an
heiligabend
dabei hatten sich erstmal nur die
unterhändler von eu und großbritannien
geeinigt doch jetzt haben alle 27 ihre
zustimmung signalisiert auch die
bundesregierung nach einer internen
schaltkonferenz übermorgen stimmen
britische abgeordnete über den pakt ab
bei einem jahr wäre ein ungeregelter brh
exit wohl abgewendet
ja die einigung beim rexit und das
corona hilfspaket in den usa sicher zwei
faktoren für das allzeithoch des dachses
heute sehen am main ist an der
frankfurter börse
ja genau aber damit nicht genug zu den
faktoren brachse diehl und us
konjunkturpaket kommt der korona
impfstart in deutschland hinzu und die
niedrigen zinsen
letztere sorgen dafür dass gerne in
immobilien oder aktienmarkt investiert
wird da andere investitionen wenig
rendite bringen
außerdem sind anleger auch nur menschen
wie froh sind dieses jahr 2020 endlich
hinter sich zu lassen
und hoffnungsvoll ins neue jahr starten
wollen am frankfurter parkett gab es
deshalb eine noch nie da gewesene
jahresend-rally der dax schließt den
handel heute mit einem stand von 13.700
90 punkten anderthalb prozent im plus
dieses jahr waren vor allem die technik
unternehmen die großen gewinner
kommendes jahr rechnet man an der börse
mit einem boom der alten industrien und
hofft dass sie wieder die nase am
aktienmarkt vorn haben dürften unter
anderem die autoindustrie und die
reisebranche
beide sparten dürfte die hoffentlich
bald erfolgende rückkehr zur normalität
zu neuem schwung verhelfen
danke für die eine ordnung sina wie brad
pitt einigung ist immerhin eine gute
nachricht für die deutschen unternehmen
ansonsten war das ablaufende jahr für
die meisten ein desaster
was aber wird das nächste jahr bringen
eine entsprechende umfrage ergibt ein
gemischtes bild gastgewerbe und
einzelhandel zum beispiel sind sehr
skeptisch
die industrie dagegen vorsichtig
optimistisch peter böhme riesige
landmaschinen für den hunger einer
wachsenden weltbevölkerung rekord ernten
in den letzten jahren etwa in russland
und nordamerika diese branche des
maschinenbauers lebt auch in
krisenzeiten die mähdrescher von claas
in harsewinkel etwa dem fünftgrößten
landmaschinen hersteller weltweit
rekordumsatz trotz co
gerade in solchen situationen lernt man
erst mal wieder wertschätzen
wie wichtig geben die eigene ernährung
auch ist und ohne landmaschinen ist eben
die welternährung gar nicht möglich und
das gibt natürlich auch in den
kritischen situationen immer wieder
nachfrageschub der maschinenbau eine der
branchen die zuversichtlich in das
kommende jahr geht und das gilt für
viele branchen etwa chemie oder auto
laut einer umfrage des instituts der
deutschen wirtschaft erwarten 26 von 43
branchen- eine höhere produktion
voraussetzung das ende der pandemie
was wir aber sehen ist das mit der
wirksamkeit oder in dem einsatz des
impfstoffes die annahme immer wichtiger
realistischer wird dass eine
normalisierung des wirtschafts- und
gesellschaftslebens dann eintreten kann
in diesem jahr nicht nur bei uns sondern
andere volkswirtschaften sind voran
allerdings dass vor kroner niveau werden
viele branchen so schnell nicht
erreichen und bei den investitionen
warten die unternehmen laut der umfrage
noch abbremste stadt gaspedal unter
mangelnden investitionen würden vor
allem die bauwirtschaft und die
kreditwirtschaft leiden
für den arbeitsmarkt ist die stimmung
gar negativ nur fünf verbände erwarten
mehr beschäftigung 23 weniger
das sind natürlich noch erhebliche
bereinigungen dabei war branchen die das
schon länger machen wie die
kreditwirtschaft weil sie in der
konsolidierung ist aber insgesamt ist
man auch hier eher vorsichtig die
wirtschaft im nächsten jahr
zuversicht wenn sie sich denn wieder
frei entfalten kann
und jetzt zu einem urteil das
menschenrechtler und
journalistenverbände gleichermaßen
empört in china entschieden richter in
einem schnellverfahren die bürger
journalistin john john muss für vier
jahre in haft sie hatte während des
corona ausbruchs kritische videos aus
johann veröffentlicht wohl freller
berichtet sie ist eine der wenigen
bürger reporterinnen gewesen die nach
johann forum zu beginn des virus
ausbruchs über die lage zu berichten
changan zeigt das chaos in den
krankenhäusern und dass es viel mehr
tote gab als offiziell erwähnt was hier
passiere sei eine tragödie für das land
so ihre worte
heute ist der prozess in shanghai
gewesen gut abgesichert von der polizei
langsam wurde zu vier jahren haft
verurteilt ihre berichteten die ruhe in
china gestört und kann das nicht
ertragen
das gilt vor allem für die korona
grenzen vor einem jahr wurde der
ausbruch des virus in johann bekannt
aber die machthaber verschwiegen zu
beginn die katastrophe dann der locker
und am 23 januar die millionenmetropole
wird wie viele weitere regionen in china
über monate abgeriegelt presidential ist
stolz auf seine corona strategie denn
das land steht besser da als viele
andere
jeder der zweifel an chinas erfolg seht
bekommen probleme das hat der prozess in
shanghai gezeigt das land sieht sich als
gewinner in der weltweiten corona krise
die machthaber glauben dass sich ihr
autoritäres system als überlegen
erwiesen hat
in peking gibt es jetzt ein paar neue
fälle sofort wird engmaschig
kontrolliert und viele bürger auf corona
getestet china wird seine erfolge nicht
verspielen
und jetzt zum sport und zur norbert und
zur darts wm in london da hat ein
deutscher für furore gesorgt allerdings
denn ein außenseiter entthronte den king
of darts gabriel clemens besiegt als
erster deutscher einen titelverteidiger
nämlich peter wright und steht als
erster deutscher überhaupt im
achtelfinale noch lange nach seinem
letzten wurf war gabriel clemens
überwältigt von dem was er im legendären
londoner er repair geleistet hatte schon
nach aussage des schwerts genießen und
versuchen im hafen kam zu mir schon von
beginn an entwickelte sich zwischen
weltmeister peter wright und dem
außenseiter ein spektakuläres duell im
fünften satz kam der deutsche mit einem
144 er finish zurück die führung zum 3 2
und auch in den folgenden durchgängen
beeindruckte der saarländer in seinem
erst zweiten profijahr mit den normen
nervenstärke im siebten satz die
entscheidung 4 zu 3 die überraschung
perfekt im achtelfinale kann der german
scheint für die nächste sensation sorgen
ex manager christian heidel kehrt nach
medienberichten zum abstiegsbedrohten
fußball bundesligisten mainz 05 zurück
und wird neuer sportvorstand neuer
sportdirektor soll der frühere mainzer
coach martin schmitt werden die
trainerfrage noch offen
vierschanzen-tournee qualifikation in
oberstdorf elf von zwölf deutschen
springern sind weiter das polnische team
aber mit titelverteidiger david kubacki
durfte wegen eines positiven kroner test
nicht antreten
die qualifikation in oberstdorf nicht
nur ohne zuschauer sondern auch ohne das
polnische team der springer clemens
branca war beim obligatorischen corona
test vor turnierstart positiv dass
aufgrund der umstände von der anreise
und so weiter
leider alle teammitglieder vom team
polen dieser k1 zuzuordnen sind nur an
karst teamkameraden als kontaktpersonen
ersten grades sind vorerst in quarantäne
für die topspringer kam ist doch sieger
2018 und titelverteidiger david kubatzki
ist der tourneesieg nun unerreichbar
erst seit der qualifikation bei stetig
schwieriger werdenden bedingungen wird
der österreicher philipp aschenwald mit
128 einhalb metern bester deutscher kam
als 14
die entscheidung morgen in oberstdorf
live bei uns im zdf ab 16
danke norbert und wir bleiben noch für
einen moment sportlich mit us
basketballprofi stephen curry und diesem
video aus dem training gezielt von
jenseits der dreipunktelinie und trifft
und trifft und trifft und trifft und
trifft in gut fünf minuten 105 dreier
hintereinander ohne einen einzigen
fehlversuch sommerwetter zu den
feuchtkalten aussichten wenig
sonnenschein dafür immer wieder schnee
und regen einzelheiten gleich von
gunther tiersch das war es von uns danke
für ihr interesse
das heute journal um 23 uhr mit marietta
slomka und hier freut sich morgen
barbara halt ich auf sie einen
angenehmen abend noch tschüss
[Musik]
mit dem zuschauer es bleibt bei uns
nasskalt schon heute nacht kann es sehr
glatt werden mit schnee im osten später
auch mit schneeregen im norden und auch
von südwesten wird es wieder losgehen
mit schnee und regen tagsüber dann vor
allen dingen am vormittag noch massiv
hier in der mitte am main
ansonsten wird es schwächer und
nachmittags noch vom niederrhein bis
nach oberfranken auch an der küste wird
es trockener und zwischendurch kann auch
die sonne scheinen bei diesem kräftigem
südwestwind die temperaturen na ja die
sind ein bisschen niedriger als heute
meist so null bis fünf grad sechs grade
lausitz oder auch hier am oberrhein und
die aussichten dass bleibt nasskalt aber
im neuen jahr kann es etwas sonniger
werden ihnen noch einen schönen abend
und macht es gut